Speaker 1: Let's let's speak next to Zack
from Toronto, Canada. Zack, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: I was I was curious because I
saw a video on you talking about socialism.
I was curious of your reasoning of why you
think the means of production should be
privately owned rather than publicly owned.
Speaker 1: Well, so I approach it a different way.
And my approach would be why would the means of
production, which might be built by an individual
paid for by an individual
insured by an individual,
financed by an individual, why should ownership
be taken away and either made societal or in a
communistic sense, state owned? Why why would
we do that? What would be the justification from
taking it away from the individual that built it?
Speaker 3:
Huh? OK, I am I guess I never thought
about it from like the lottery perspective.
Speaker 1: Well, I mean, apply it to anything,
right? So so you're sort of like for me,
the action that would be required to be justified
would be why would why would we be allowed to
change the ownership structure of someone?
That's something that someone built. If you
you know, you go to school and you learn
plumbing, for example, and then you go and you
buy all the plumbing equipment, you might take
out a loan to buy that plumbing equipment. And
you're a plumber for a bunch of time. And then
at a certain point, you get big enough where you
start hiring apprentice plumbers and all these
different things. So it's your business. You
own the equipment, you hire the employees. What
would be the justification for saying, OK, now the
business is no longer yours, now it belongs to all
of your employees or it belongs to the state. What
would be the justification for that?
Speaker 3: Um.
I am not sure, actually, I I'm personally
not a socialist, but I'm interested in.
Socialist theory, and I was just I was curious
of why you personally weren't a socialist,
but I mean that yeah, that does make sense.
Speaker 1: So I have a ton more broadly. I have
a ton of videos about why I'm not a socialist. But
to answer that specific question, it's because I
don't think there's any justification for it.
Speaker 3: OK, great, thanks, David. I
appreciate hearing your perspective.
Speaker 1: I appreciate the question.
Thank you so much for calling in.